c'est en mars 2010neuf que christian
quesada et placé en détention provisoire
pour corruption de mineurs et détention
et diffusion d'imagés
pédopornographiques avec christian
quesada le grand champion du jeu les 12
coups de midi ont été mises en examen et
écroué pour corruption mineurs est
question quesada qui a reconnu les faits
qui lui sont reprochés durant sa garde à
vue
l'année suivante il est condamné à trois
ans de prison ferme par la justice
l'homme devenu célèbre en 2016 pour
saisie manga au jeu de tf1 les 12 coups
de midi avait vu son rêve se transformer
en cauchemar en quelques jours
sauf que voilà aujourd'hui christian
quesada et de nouveau un homme libre
c'est le journal le progrès qui révèle
l'information et qui indique que
l'ancien maître de midi aurait quitté le
département de l'ain et serait rentré
chez lui en raison du principe des
remises de peine escient quesada a pu
sortir de prison en purgeant deux des
trois années pour lesquelles il a été
condamné
si pour certains il a purgé sa peine
c'est normal qu'ils puissent de nouveau
vivre librement pour d'autres sa sortie
prématurée est une injustice
alors christian quesada soir de prison
etes-vous choqué alors christian quesada
sort de prison et sachez que lundi on
aura des images exclusives dans tpm paix
du dock de guillaume genton je vous le
dis on les aura lundi
ça sera à ne pas manquer bien sûr dans
et pmp christian quesada sort de prison
etes-vous choqué c'est la question que
vous pose donc il était condamné à trois
ans de prison par an de prison il en
prison depuis 2019 il a pris trois ans
de prison 2010 9,3 à 2022 pourquoi il
sort avant parce qu'il a bénéficié d'une
remise de peine
ce qui sous-entend qu'il sait entre
guillemets bien comportée en prison
c'était un détenu modèle c'est pour ça
qu'il est sorti avant c'est ce que c'est
ce qu'on nous a dit rajiv il ya deux
types de réduction de peine pour tous
les détenus le crédits de réduction de
peine ces trois mois pour la première
année et deux mois après donc ça lui
fait 5 mois et ensuite comme il s'est
bien comporté il ya une réduction
supplémentaire qui s'appelle l'effort de
réadaptation sociale et ça c'est très
important il a été à bourg en bresse un
détenu modèle il a changé de look et
donc l'administration pas eu les cheveux
longs une barbe et cheveux longs barbe
il se veut méconnaissable et
l'administration lui a reconnu le droit
de sortir sans risquer de troubler
l'ordre public
il a un suivi socio-judiciaire très dure
55 ans donc c'est à dire pour grey
obligé d'être suivi par un psychiatre de
faire amende honorable
s'il ne le fait pas il retourne en
prison d'accord il est inscrit au
fichier des délinquants sexuels
donc on se dit on l'espère qu'il ne
pourra plus recommencer
il a déjà quitté le département de l'ain
et très probablement lui aurait aimé
partir à l'étranger échapper aux
paparazzi
notamment il est déjà pisté par des
paparazzis en ce moment qui veulent
absolument la photo mais l'étranger ça
va être compliqué parce que le suivi
c'est vraiment d'être informé par un
psychiatre de deux de vos évolutions de
votre mentalité donc il pourra pas aller
à l'étranger clair chaque langue et avec
mercy clair j'étais là un seul à quatres
le rappeur dont il suit pas très bien je
suis désolé je
gage partout c'est comme un achat nous
nageons 20 jeunes abrutis claire version
bas ou un précaire comme ça ce
travail-là clair vous avez détrôner
christian quesada pour vous est-ce que
la peine de deux ans et suffisante alors
moi en tant que juriste oui je peux me
dire oui en tant que femme et en tant
que maman nous n'avons pas du tout
d'ailleurs que je pense que c'est quand
même monsieur qui avait déjà eu des
histoires de ce genre à l'époque
et voilà qu'il a fait a été condamné à 3
ans il a fait que deux ans que peut-être
que toutes les victimes n'ont pas encore
porté plainte que peut-être qu'il ya eu
des choses mais c'est le point de vue de
la justice et canton juriste je le
comprends mais quand on pas m'en vois ça
me révolte
j'ai très peur qui recommence même avec
un sociaux suivi je suis pas un sociaux
sur une piste socio judiciaire a suivi
socio-judiciaire pardon à bord d'un de
ses vieux et l'a6 lyon ça peut limiter
le risque et il ya un risque vous
bernard montiel vous dites quoi non moi
je dis que c'est tout à fait normal il a
purgé sa peine bon il est vrai que les
affaires traitées c'était les quatre
jeunes filles mineures
c'était entre avril 2007 et mars 2009 je
crois et puis la détention d'imagés
pédopornographiques
c'est sûr que s'il a pas s'il ne se fait
pas ce suivi on risque effectivement il
ya toujours ça revient quoi
malheureusement il fallait ce que vous
dites
à ceux qui disent qu'ils ont il a payé
sa dette maintenant il a fait deux ans
qu est ce que vous leur dites ah oui en
tant que juriste effectivement je pense
qu'il faut croire on la réinsertion des
personnes sinon on arrête et on fait des
condamnations à perpétuité donc
effectivement c'est toujours intéressant
de proposer des portes de sortie elle
pour les personnes qui ont commis des
infractions par contre voilà je vous dis
en tant que maman je me dis que quand
même un homme qui avait des contenus
pornographiques avec des enfants sur son
ordinateur à dire des choses vraiment
malsaines qui est dans la rue et ça ça
me gêne beaucoup france et qu'on peut
pas on peut préserver ses valeurs
oui mais comme moi je trouve que la
remise de peine pour dévoiler les
criminels qui ont braqué je trouve ça
tout à fait normal dans son cas précis
on sait très bien que les délinquants
sexuels et notamment ceux qui sont
couverts de la pédophilie on sait mais
la vente la récidive c'est un vrai de
criminalité voilà c'est un vrai un gros
propre vrai problème et je trouve ça
très très dommageable qu'on libère
effectivement un en avant ses vidéos moi
je suis comme vous en tant que parent
j'ai pas envie d'avoir de savoir ces
gens là sont dehors
delphine aussi tout à fait d'accord avec
20 jamin pour tout ce qui est
crimes meurtres et tout ce qui est
sexuel faudrait pas qu'ils de remise de
peine parce que c'est comme ça valérie
il ya effectivement la morale l'émotion
moi aussi je suis maman et moi aussi
évidemment je rêvais souhaité que la
peine soit complète et entière mais
après il ya une question de droit et le
droit c'est que voilà et donc il
il n'a pas bénéficié part parce que il
très dans une certaine notoriété autres
il a été là pour le coup comme un
prisonnier lambda voilà ce qu'on peut le
regretter ou pas mais c'est alors que
vous j'ai envie d'avoir la vie de sa
team voilà qu'à qui a 16 ans vous
comment vous avez quand vous vous sentez
voilà comment vous vous répercuter
s'acheva en fait moi je trouve ça super
dangereux faut savoir qu'en 2003 il
avait déjà été condamné à deux mois de
prison avec sursis pour exhibition
sexuelle
donc pour moi c'est un homme qui restera
dangereux forcément à vie alors je dis
pas qu'ils qui lui faut forcément une
prison à vie mais je pense que oui il
faut des peines plus longues et comme
l'a dit des films comme l'a dit benjamin
il faut effectivement mais en fait pas
de remise de peine pour des personnes
avec vraiment des genres de maladie
mentale dans ce style là qu'ils peuvent
être vraiment dangereux surtout pour les
enfants
on se sent pas c'est que enfin on peut
pas se sentir en sécurité avec des
personnes comme ça en liberté sous si
peu de temps on paie pas alors les tous
les curés qui ont fait ses conneries on
les laisse en liberté en échange de
paroisses et toutes séparées
c'est une âme à la digue et votre
relationnel sont pas été jugé alors
c'est ça mais bien sûr la caméra qui
capte et a pris deux ans vous dit non
vous allez gilles et magali magail moi
je pense qu'il ya une vraie faille
juridique effectivement sur ce genre de
problème
maintenant après il faut pas non plus
faire une double peine dans le sens où
c'est christian quesada c'est une
affaire qui a été médiatisé et je pense
que doux du coup il est devenu un petit
peu le il avait trois ans à du tourisme
est ce que je veux dire c'est que les
questions si les remises de peine dans
ces cas précis dans ces cas là oui mais
il faudrait remise de peine dans ces
cas-là mais choqué parce qu'il ya un
vrai problème au niveau juridique
aujourd'hui en france à ce niveau là j
s'il n'y a pas de remise de peine à ce
moment là un détenu n'aura aucune
perspective
parce qu'à pas une exception christian
quesada ne peut pas faire une exception
et assurant et benjamin conversation
donc je comprends votre point de vue
excusez moi être entre entre le délit
entre entre ballades je fais une
connerie tu bosses tu vois quelque chose
tu prends trois ans ont déjà tout ça
beaucoup dé bon d'accord c'est autre
chose
astral et moi ça ne me dérange pas
effectivement situe entre habitations
qui sortent mais dans son cas à lui
passer la loi quant à lui nommé son cas
lui c'est pour me connais tous ces cas
là on sait que d'aller nos neuf fois sur
dix ces gens là vont recommencer mérite
malheureusement malheureusement lepage
aux événements des trois ans il est né
condamné à trois ans et libération
diffusé la photo d'ailleurs on peut
répondre à benjamin puisque c'est le cas
depuis 2001 et je rappelle quand même
corruption de mineure une émission
sexuelle trois ans déjà
bon je suis pas juge mais trois ans déjà
c'est pas cher payé il aurait dû prendre
beaucoup plus
cet homme est dangereux cet homme est
malade aux etats unis un avantage c'est
qu'on a une application est gris quand
vous avez un criminel autour de vous il
ya une application qui vous permet de
savoir où il est lui on sait pas où il
est mais qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
70% des cas fédérer si bienvenue donc le
mec il va récidiver
donc je trouve que c'est pas cher payé
et qu est scandaleux mais vraiment du
monde à lucky et une remise de peine
vous raconter une anecdote dans un
instant claires justes guillaume
terrebonne moi je ne suis pas juste
c'est pas moi de fixer les sanctions
évidemment mais pour avoir eu accès au
dossier
récemment je peux vous dire que ce café
crise en quesada ces infâmes et abjects
ça fait deux ans qu'on parle de cette
affaire on aura donc les infos lundi
voilà on a fait de nous donner résumé
sans entrer dans les détails mais toney
doute on a fait des documentaires on
pense
et qu'ils détenaient juste entre guilhem
cissé déjà horrible des images de
mineurs etc
ça va beaucoup plus loin que ça il ya de
la manipulation il ya des fausses
identités il prenait des photos alors
insu de jeunes mineurs dans la rue pour
se masturber après ils échangent et les
images avec d'autres gens il les regarde
avec des personnes il se faisait passer
pour une jeune femme en demandant à des
mineurs de leur envoyer des photos de
leur poitrine pour après leur promettre
une rencontre avec quelqu'un de connu de
la télé en l'occurrence christian
quesada y fixer une grille de tarifs
pour mater ses s'emballe pour toucher
ces 200 balles pour faire l'amour c'est
300 balles donc franchement je ne suis
pas juge je ne suis pas avocat ni rien
mais je trouve que la sanction de deux
ans elle est très légère cambrai voilà
la vraie la vraie question c'est comme
l'a dit benjamin et comment tu arrivé
dans la volaille et voilà c'est et c'est
ça qui fait flipper qui vous le suisse à
faire et bien de me suivre statines
alors clair vous vous lavez revu depuis
les 12 coups de midi
alors oui effectivement je l'avais vu à
deux occasions donc je les ai rencontrés
le jour où j'ai gagné les deux connu dix
s'est très bien passé ya rien à dire sur
ce moment là je les rêves une deuxième
fois au moment des masters du jeu donc
je leur ai vu mais sachant qu'il est
extrêmement froid c'était vraiment un
autre visage de lui et voilà quelqu'un
de très froides voilà peut-être pas
spécialement sympathique en tout cas et
après je les revues une troisième fois
parce que quand il a sorti son livre il
a fait la promotion de son livre il
était venu à lille sur le marché de noël
est donc comme je suis originaire de la
région lilloise
j'étais venu à le rejoindre m'avait
demandé de passer sur le stand pour
faire un peu de promotion donc vous
étiez venu c'est même pas lui c'est son
éditeur qui m'avait contacté
donc j'étais venu il était avec son co
auteur sur place et qu'on a chez les
petites animations sur le marché noël et
après nous sommes allés manger un petit
saut ensemble et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
jeune femme qu'il connaissait des
réseaux sociaux qu'il a rejoint à ce
moment là donc qu'il n'avait jamais vue
auparavant
et il a eu un comportement qui était
quand même je pense un peu problématique
alors à l'époque je pensais que c'était
un homme qui était nageurs à 1 avait 25
26 ans elle était consentante être très
content de rencontrer christian quesada
mais j'ai quand même senti un petit
malaise parce qu'il était extrêmement
tactile avec elle et savait que moi
j'étais là je sais que le père de ma
fille j'étais avec ma fille dans un
restaurant
et si il apparaissait beaucoup c'était
quand même très très gênant pour moi
pour ma famille
et voilà c'est tout je n'ai pas su le
fin mot de l'histoire parce que ça me
séparer et c'est vrai que j'avais
proposée on
plusieurs perches à cette jeune femme en
disant si tu veux on te ramener à la
gare voilà c'est pas très content
ailleurs qu'on le fasse
en tout cas on avait essayé de laisser
en tout cas des portes de sortie est
cette jeune femme
avec le recul j'aurais dû être plus
insistantes c'est mon côté maman mais
dit peut-être que j'aurais dû de plus
insistantes le sentais qu'il y avait un
petit malaise mais à l'époque je ne
savais pas les tenants et les
aboutissants mais je le regrette
beaucoup
j'avais su j'aurais été plus insistant
il ya deux aspects en fait j'écris sans
quesada d'un côté il ya quelqu'un qui
est bon qu'il ya une vie qui était
compliqué inquiété comme sdf qui est
devenu une star du jour au lendemain et
qui a profité de sa notoriété pour
devenir un homme à femmes ça encore ça
le regarde lui il ya des choses qui sont
légales vous parler de deux jeunes
femmes qui étaient consentants qui est
beaucoup de familles lille avait de
nombreuses partenaires et après il ya
tout ce qui est illégal et les
détentions de photos de mineurs
attention et de vidéos on parle de viols
d'enfants de moins de 10 ans assez
horrible il faut vraiment distinguer ces
deux choses il ya ce qui est légal et le
fait qu'il ait profité de sa notoriété
et tout ce qui est vraiment abjecte qui
avait sur son ordinateur mais j'ai vu
des choses mais ils montrent vraiment
immonde aurait alors la malade un
dossier on en parlera lundi puisque on
aura même des des images exclusives de
votre dock et c'est vrai que voilà c'est
dit les informations incroyable que vous
avez guillaume genton moi je pense alors
en principe aussi ce qui est très très
intelligente christian qui s'attaquerait
aux 1100 à peine pour bonne conduite
well as dû comprendre comment se
comporter comment être en prison pour
pouvoir avoir une remise de peine d'un
an héros c'est vrai il est très
intelligent il est très cultivé
donc il devait avoir et je peux vous
dire voilà il a c'est quelqu'un qui est
voilà qui fait manipulateur donc voilà
il faut faire attention et même après
vous savez lui il a déjà peut-être mis
en place sa sortie ce qu'il allait faire
après d'où l'importance du suivi des
psycho d'où l'importance du suivi mais
mais mais mais aussi vie il est
tellement fort
il va leur attention tu écologique pour
info il n'a pas le droit de parler de
l'affairé n'a pas le droit de faire de
l'isf un droit de faire de film pas le
droit d'accorder une interview pour
l'instant pendant 13 heures à nathan et
bien